hi my name is markiplier and welcome to
walkmaster you ever walk
good great we're gonna try that now
except on stilts except for a goat and
except i gotta use my thumb apparently
drag your thumb to control the leg i do
that
oh no oh no it's kwop
oh no it's quap on stilts oh no oh no
it's quap up stills
oh no oh no it's quap
oh yeah oh this is the good stuff
oh yeah oh yeah
okay interesting
did i jump was that mirrored was that
something else
the hell did that
okay how did i jump
okay
don't bite my taint please okay
hey hey that's pretty good
what made me want to play it is um it
seems like it's going to get real
difficult real quick
which i'm probably right about that
[Music]
at what point do i rip my legs in half
there we go okay
so far so good
all right this is easy so far not bad
i think i think it i thought that was
the sound of my entire grundle snapping
in half
all right oh i guess we're good so far i
don't know why goat needs to do this
but here he is
[Music]
i touched it i touched it
wow holy crap okay that counts you can
fling yourself bodily into the finish
line and it still works out
okay that's good so long as i don't mind
a little blame damage i think i'll be
okay
what is this supposed okay
okay and please don't
all right so i i think i spoke too soon
this is actually going to be a bit more
difficult than i
suspected
no forward forward backwards okay
all right so some of these can break or
something like that
but other than that i'm okay hey
that's pretty good loading sponsor oh
[Music]
oh my god go away also you know that's
the right way to do it i played like
four
three levels and a tutorial before i
even got a single ad that's how you do
it
you don't want it in your mobile game
goddamn mobile
game greedy blood sucking bastards you
don't just start
slamming mobile ads as soon as someone
gets in the game
that's how you get people to jump right
out and uninstall it right away
if you need to be ad supported i get it
hey i'm on youtube
here's an ad right now see you know
convenient timing so that people can get
around it and then they can get on
everything that they want
i'm not one to speak because in youtube
they automatically put one at the
beginning of every video
so i guess i can't really talk about
this but we all understand it's part of
the process to make it all
as good as possible the difference is
the youtubers that just spam every
single
possible segment of time i'm gonna do a
video
at some point in the future you can't be
mad about this but i'm gonna do a video
at some point in the future
that is literally an experiment of how
many ads i can put in a single video
and you will get a prize based on how
far you make it
you'll actually get no prize i don't
think i'm allowed to incentivize stuff
like that but in the comments you'll get
bragging rights of saying how many ads
you were able to consider
so you can't get mad about me about that
because i'm saying it right now and i'm
being very meta about it and because i'm
being self-aware
and i'm doing it ironically it won't be
anything bad
right this is how i get away from what
are you
i'm sorry i almost tried to under your
stinger there
just something that something about it
really just made me want to fall mouth
egg
towards it i really i did it well
good for me good thing there's no
punishment for dying
are these beets
these sick beats here
there's something about like just a bee
floating in front of you just like you
irresistible urge to anybody ever get
that
is it just me this is kind of
though that i would actually not mind
paying a few bucks for
you know i don't know if it's just me
but what in the
what kind of farm what kind of farm is
in technology like this
what kind of farm has this a cobblestone
road on a
what a freaking fan what kind of
nightmare farm
oh did i hit how did i do that how did i
skip
we're getting into some advanced tactics
there's something about like
there's an ability to skip and i want to
know what it is
skip my skin ah shoot okay forget it
it'll happen accidentally
so you got to let go in order to switch
to the other footage
maybe that's a trick i let go first what
just happened did i die it sounded like
flesh being exploded off of my bones
but apparently not okay raining
volcano
where am i i was on a farm not two
minutes ago my taint
whoa what did i do okay so if you tap
if you tap oh speed
this is pro moves this is pro moves my
dude wink
okay ah yeah that's how we do
weird okay so it's something about okay
it's
oh my god oh my god
i made it this game is actually fun like
i'm i'm actually having quite a good
time
what are you gonna do you're gonna you
gotta eat me
you're gonna eat me i'm gonna try to
leap off of this watch this
boink oh
necessitate a reaction like that but i
was just excited
oh shoot oh shoot oh shoot survive
survive survive
survive we gotta survive
[Music]
okay all right here we go and then boink
and then
no ah all right it's getting a bit
more difficult and i'm getting a bit
more stupid which is not the
ideal combination for these things
what's this
by random oh oh oh oh oh
oh mr sure man yeah
i'll do mr garfield
wow i missed the goat i missed the goat
what is the point of this bridge who
built this bridge
i'm gonna dri
well at least you float okay all right
this is gonna be tough
okay it's it suddenly got a lot more
difficult
and by a lot more difficult i mean i'm
real bad i never actually got better at
the game
oh no here we go this is where i lose it
this is where i suddenly start to say
how much i hate the game when in reality
it's just my skill level that's
that's getting me to not be what do you
do here
what oh there's shallow water
oh no yeah i'm an idiot
okay making progress doing
uh why do i need to be on stilts why is
this a necessity
who deemed this rodent necessary to have
stalts
please please i'm pranking you i'm
begging you please
please please
oh no oh no oh
no oh no i've lost all ability to do
even the most
basic of walks
i did it again i did the same thing i
know why i'm trying to get good at like
the the
the advanced tactics so that in the
future
when i get to the things that actually
need the advanced tactics i will be able
to do the advanced tactics you know what
i mean
it's all part of my master strategy
don't ask
why i don't even know why because no one
can know
the genius of my boy that was easy when
i
did what i was supposed to do boy that
was sure
easy boy that was really easy no i'm not
gonna watch an
ad for more coins i would never do that
oh my god okay cool man i would never do
that
i've standards and now it's winter
uh oh i know what this is going to do i
see i see
okay all right okay it's about to get
tough
okay this is where my grundle gets
ripped in plane
in twain i say it
oh
okay well dive face first into it yeah
that's the way to do whoa okay i didn't
do that
leap nice nice nice that's how you do
that's how you do
perfect i'm god damn great at this
there we go this is how we do this is
how we do ignore the moving glaciers
it's part of
climate change don't ask any questions
about it best play in ignorance here
hello yeah ah yes the helicopter bridge
perfect why is there why is there camper
on skis back there you know
i gotta give it for the developers in
terms of style on this cause
they really got the style going be
careful
careful you wouldn't want to mess
anything up like
my flexible grundle
i hear much is there just like a troop
of clowns
juggling chainsaws down there
i would love to believe that boing i
need the jump
ah shoot okay
so what i need to do is not okay go go
go
my balls my balls
i'm good challenge unlocked i like the
sound of a challenge
can i please skip it's a lot of ads it's
a lot of ads i will admit it's still a
lot of ads
okay fear of heights what is this
there's a lot of levels in this game
that's very impressive
hello who's here oh my god
oh no well if i run right into it i'm
not gonna get very far
am i
[Music]
what do i do
wow that's really something
oh the bandage yeah for all the brain
damage yeah that makes sense
crown nah don't get the it's too
expensive
i can get different stilts give me
staltz
yellow wait hold on a second
yellow are my eyes just broken on this
cause that don't look yellow
it's just decapitated giraffe what did
you do to the giraffes
i'm gonna go for another character
[Music]
lenny no i don't want lenny oh
all right what do you get what do you
got what do you got i love it
i love it yes please clown fish
i hate it i hate it oh boy
i love it i love it never mind i love it
i didn't know if that was actually gonna
break on me but it sure seemed like a
wood okay come here you
yeah launch me launch me launch me
launch me launch me
oh leg longly here we go
man i'm getting good at this i'm getting
goddamn good at this
my i would be fine i'm a fish
when's it gonna get tough when's it
gonna get tough again
oh look at that
look at the me this game is goddamn
pleasant
this game's got oh god oh god oh
no ain't a problem ain't a problem for
the likes of me
genius
this is good stuff oh my god
we're fine we're fine why are we not
fine we're fine
we are fine no
okay this is actually getting a lot
tougher really quickly i have to
understand the dynamics of physics and
how the rotational r r r r
r easy peasy turns out the answer was
patience
turns out the answer was not running
straight oh no
oh my mouth is ready my mouth is ready
my bee buddy
one second all right here we go man
nailing it i'm
nailing this uh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh we're fine
yes please my friends
that's very cute though well if i was
gonna listen to a sponsor anyway i would
have just taken the thing to
uh it's a bit much it is a bit much
okay let's not get smooshed in the brain
okay we're good we're good oh my god
we're good
we're good we're good we're good we're
we are good we are good my friends we
are good
okay leg longly
leg longly leg long
i am a genius i am a genius i'm a genius
here i come volcano
you ain't going to get me i'm a genius
i'm a gene oh my god
i'm a genius i'm a genius i'm a genius
i'm a goddamn jesus yes
[Music]
i like the clownfish i do not like this
sound fish
hi who the hell are you spo
who who in the hell are you chasing
after me
are you coming to kill me are you coming
to kill me oh my god he's coming to kill
me oh my god he's coming
oh my god what happened
[Music]
what the frick was you all right
oh my god oh my god boing please no
no no no no no no no
no no how are you are you
at all supposed to be able to get out of
those situations or is it just i'm
stupid and the answer is i should never
be in this situation in the first place
come back to me come back come back to
me come back to me come back to me
oh god okay center mass
center mass sentra mass
center map perfect okay here we go no
no okay we're fine
we're fine we're fine yeah we're good
we're good we're good
glacier be damned oh my
goodness oh my goodness center mass
perfect center mass i am a genius
i am a god i'm pretty good
okay all right let's see let's see
let's see oh no do i you
no oh well if i can't even
if i can't even do anything about it
then it's not okay what a
jump
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god hello
i did it i'm a genius who just walks
around
nice okay this is how you do it
right this is how you do it okay
this is how you do it oh this is how you
do it i'm
getting really good at this guys and
guys i'm getting really good at this i
don't know why you're laughing
but i'm getting extremely good at this
i'm getting
bananas learn to jump i already
knew how to jump dude i knew how
to jump see i've always
i already been prepared for it
you think i didn't already boo okay if i
slam my balls as hard as i can on the
cliff's edge what happens to me
oh yeah oh yeah
blammo i am so good
hey i'm the goat again that's cool all
right how are you going to make me do
this
nonstop okay right into the mouth of the
beast
nice careful
i'm going i'm going oh my god i'm going
i'm oh my god i'm go oh my god i'm going
yes
yes yes i'm a genius oh no yes
okay oh my god don't jump
oh my god i'm going i'm going i'm going
i'm going
i'm going now
damn it that would have been really cool
if i could have done that all at one but
i didn't
because it's stupid no
please not like this ah okay
okay i'm gonna do just a couple more
because otherwise i'll be here all day
this game is actually surprisingly fun
not sponsored but it could be
why what
okay
[Music]
oh my god i'm so good i'm so
goddamn good all right i'm gonna i'm
gonna call it there i did pretty good
uh obviously because i'm at the beginner
it means that i'm very good at the game
um i beat the first few levels which are
always the hardest it always gets easier
from there
so i don't need to worry about anything
it's all it's all part of the plan
it's all good don't worry about it i'm
i'm an expert at this so thank you
everybody so much for watching like i
said not sponsored about this but if you
want to play this game it's in the
description below a few too many ads
that's what i'm going to say
just just a few too many ads you know if
you're getting an ad every like minute
or so that that
that might be indicative of too many ads
so thank you everybody so much for
watching
let me know you thought down in the
comments below and as always i will see
you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]
you